you know Patrick I never aspired to be a
made man
you know I I was on a different path in
life but I was 17 years old when my dad
drew a 50 year prison sentence and went
off to serve his federal time and I sat
with my dad I visited him in the federal
jail before they shipped him off to the
penitentiary and he said to me Michael
I'm innocent I didn't commit this crime
it was alleged to have masterminded a
nationwide string of bank robberies he
said I never knew the witnesses I'm not
a bank robber the witnesses were all
drug addicts junkies and one thing I
knew my dad hated anything to do with
drugs my whole life he preached against
her he would make up stories about drug
addicts to scare me never to take drugs
so I knew he would never bother with
people like this so I believed him and
when he went away Joe Columbo the boss
of our family who we were close with he
kind of took me under his wing because
my dad was his underboss and I started
to meet a lot more of my dad's friends
you know and they were influencing me
Mike you know what are you doing going
to school I was a pre-med student at
that time shortly after that you know if
you don't help you Father out he's gonna
die in prison so I went to see him in
Leavenworth and I said that I'm not
going to school you're gonna die in here
if I don't help he didn't want that I
mean he kind of argued no I want you to
go to school get an education I said dad
it's too late my mind is made up and he
said to me he said if you're gonna be on
the street then I want you on the street
the right way in his mind the right way
was to become a member of his life and
he proposed me at that point for
membership into the life and you know
the interesting thing pet my father even
at that point never told me what the
life was about you know you're not
supposed to talk about that life with
anybody outside of it and he wouldn't
violate that policy even with me it's on
some my dad's a good soldier he just
should go home somebody would be in
touch with you do whatever you're told
it was kind of on the job training and
two weeks later I sat with the boss and
you know he ran things down for me and
told me what to expect and for the next
year and a half I was kind of a recruit
where I kind of learned the life had to
do anything I was told to do to prove
myself worthy and then Halloween night
1975 is when it was formally inducted
into that life you remembered vividly
vividly yeah and how was what was that
process like was there ritual was there
an experience you had to go through
very very solemn ceremony very serious
six of us walked into a room
individually towards midnight that night
it was a very secure setting obviously I
walked into room the boss was seated the
head of like a horseshoe configuration
the underboss in the console area to his
left and right and all of our couple
regimes are captains alongside of them
and I walked down the aisle stood in
front of the boss I held out my hand he
took a knife right here cut my finger
some blood dropped on the floor this is
a blood oath i cupped my hands he took a
picture of a saint Catholic called the
cloud put it on my hands and lit it
aflame it didn't hurt it burned quickly
it was just symbolic and he said tonight
Michael Franzese you are born again I
had to a new life until the Cosa Nostra
this thing of ours violate what you know
about this life betray your brothers and
you will die and burn in hell like the
saint is burning in your hands
do you accept yes I do and that's it
that's the ritual that's warden sweet
but extremely serious